- [Narrator] This rail bridge
is the only border crossing
between Russia and North Korea.
In early November,
satellite imagery showed a
train crossing into Russia.
The first movement
observed there in years.
In the past,
the railway was used to
transport passengers and goods,
but Russia and North Korea
didn't return our questions
on what the train was carrying this time.
It is one sign of renewed activity
between the two countries,
which have indicated a desire
to expand their partnership.
Their leaders have exchanged letters,
Russia said it recently sent
thoroughbred horses to North Korea,
and Pyongyang is even looking to help
rebuild parts of Ukraine.
But US Intelligence says
the cooperation is deeper
(missiles swooshing)
and that Pyongyang is
selling arms to Moscow.
This would go against
United Nations sanctions,
and both countries deny the reports.
So here's what we know
about how the two isolated
nations are growing closer.
Putin and Kim haven't
officially met since 2019,
but they've exchanged at
least six letters this year.
Both leaders have regularly mentioned
the cooperation between the two countries
that's never been stronger.
(speaking Russian)
- [Narrator] Pyongyang
has been the only capital
to recognize Moscow's sham referendums
that paved the way for the Kremlin
to claim occupied Ukrainian regions
as part of the Russian Federation.
On its end, Russia has
blocked Washington led efforts
to enforce additional
sanctions on North Korea
after a recent barrage
of missile launches.
North Korea is also looking to help Moscow
on the ground in Ukraine.
(speaking Russian)
- [Narrator] In July, North
Korea's Ambassador to Russia
met with an official
from the Russian occupied Donetsk Republic
discussing joint projects in construction,
agriculture, and other sectors.
There is no evidence that North Koreans
are working in the occupied territories,
which would violate the UN ban
on the use of North Korean Labor.
Russian officials said they looked into
how to employ North Korean workers
without breaching UN resolutions.
Those international
sanctions also affect goods,
including arms sales.
- The DPRK is covertly supplying
Russia with a significant
number of artillery shells.
- [Narrator] The Democratic
People's Republic of Korea,
or DPRK, is being accused by the US
of using a network of countries
in the Middle East and North Africa
to send ammunition to Russian forces.
(tanks blasting)
Pyongyang is a major producer of arms,
holding large stockpiles.
Much of it is based on
Soviet era technology
and is very similar to Russian weapons.
All this, North Korea watchers say,
makes it an attractive source
of ammunition for Russia,
although trade of the two countries
is heavily restricted
by a slew of sanctions.
Some Western officials have assessed
that Russia is running
through its arsenal,
as military experts estimate
it fires approximately
20,000 shells per day.
As Russia grows more isolated,
it's looking for any help it can get.
The resumption of the train
traffic with North Korea,
suspended during the
pandemic, shows how Moscow
is looking to work with
its eastern neighbor.
And experts on North Korea and Russia
agree that the two countries
will only grow closer
as Russia seeks support for its war.
And North Korea,
which has been particularly
isolated in recent years,
could also benefit from a
stronger alliance with Moscow,
both politically and economically.